so john last year kind of had a
forgettable year
and you may remember that the biggest
thing we chatted about last year and it
was a
subject of great conversation and
consternation
the fact that his velo was down a couple
of miles an hour
dodgers in a road graze the 1-2 swag and
a miss
foul tipped into the glove of dom nunez
a little high
cheese for john gray seeger three more
hits last night
he's been on eight of his 11 plate
appearances so far
he's lined into center field and he
stays scalding hot
a one-out single and seeger's the first
base runner tonight
26 year old walker bueller with his
season debut
coming off the postseason where he went
2-0 with a 180
era two out trevor story stepping in he
is four
for nine and there's a fly ball to
center field racing on back bellinger
step on the warning track he makes the
catch
and the inning is over no runs no hits
no errors and nobody left
aj pollock right down right leads it off
against
john gray 02 swung on a miss second
strikeout
for gray first one was on a fastball
this one was on the slider
boy did that have some late break to it
austin barnes
the catcher in the eight hole the hitter
swing and a miss
there's some heat john gray with
strikeout number three
blackman will go to third and now
there's two gun and
josh fuentes coming up fastball couldn't
catch up to that one either struck him
out and that nz in it
blackman is stranded at third top of the
order time and here's gavin lux
pitch swung online story with a leap
brings it down
behind second base two down trevor
timed that perfectly and was able to
snare it so here's rymel tapia with two
outs nobody on here in the third
nothing nothing swinging a high drive
deep right field back goes taylor he's
at the wall
and it is gone rymel
tapia exit stage right
rocky's lead one to nothing rockies
broke out the home run
stick last night they're doing it here
in the third inning
he extends his hit straight john gray
really rolling
he's giving up a single to seeger a walk
to bellinger both those were in the
first
no base runners since payoff pitch
grounded to the right side fuentes to
his left
takes it throws onto first and it's one
two three again for john gray
with a one to nothing lead they're
hitting in the bottom of the fourth
story drives the ball to deep right
center field bellinger to the deepest
part of the yard to haul it in
just in front of the wall and slight
right center field first out of the
fourth
brian mcmahon is next with muncie
playing in front of crone
that's a base hit and that's going to
run all the way to the corner
cj crone picking up stu cole and stu is
going to send him
ball got away for a moment from pollock
crown to the plate
gets away from seeger run scores tuning
up the colorado
on the double by ryan mcmahon ryan
mcmahon stood at home plate he didn't
think this ball was going to stay
fair just watch cj after this he's like
oh man
that's a long way rios goes to third
barnes goes to second
there's two gone and gavin lux coming up
now the one two to luck swinging
and a missy got him with a slider john
gray
stonewalls the dodgers john gray
has scattered three hits one of the hits
belongs to the guy who will
lead it off for los angeles shortstop
corey seeger
hit hard and fair there's corey seeger
trying to make it initial
issue blackman will play it in but it's
a leadoff double for corey seeger
uh oh bud black heading out with steve
foster
and scott garrett one of the rockies
trainers
they're going to make a call to the
bullpen we watched his last swing
against
walker bueller you know there was a
there was kind of a grimace but it was
hard to tell because he checked swung
and fouled the pitch off what a
disappointment for the
rockies in general john gray in
particular
well we're ready to go el monte's got
the sign now muncie
muscles one left side and the first run
will cross
it eats up fuentes and it's 2-1
the only defender on the left side of
the infield an easy play and he cuffed
it
and the dodgers are within 2-1 and now
the dodgers have the bases loaded
barnes is struck out and single to left
fly ball in the short left it's going to
drop in for a base hit
in the score is muncie and
pollock scores as well and the dodgers
take a three to two lead
four consecutive two out base runners
for the dodgers and they lead it for the
first time tonight
and now our home plate umpire pat hoberg
comes out in front of the mound and
now the fountains are still running oh
there you go the home run that became a
single
cat and now the fountains
[Music]
lux with his second triple in his many
nights rockies bring the infield in
halfway
for corey seeger based it into right
field and they lead at 4-2
on another corey seeger hit his third
one
tonight dodger fans of colorado are
chanting
mvp already he's getting it on the road
one out now with mcmahon replacing crone
at first
4-2 dodgers and here's fuentes
swing
[Applause]
big swing for josh fuentes
first home run of the year game
in 2019 the minor league level hit 300
fly ball to right and deep and back
and high off the wall left fielder
phil and mckinstry circle the bases for
an inside the park home run
giving the dodgers a 5-4 lead
in the leather catapults back into the
playing field
and zach mckinstry never gets up on it
circles the bases
two on two out and chris taylor
who's over four and has been struck out
three times tonight taylor yanks one in
the air to deep left field
that's off the wall
[Applause]
seeger stopped at third to throw behind
him as he stumbles
taylor's into second with an rbi double
and the dodgers lead 6-4
now story coming up one out one on
rodgers six and the rockies four
this ball driven a left center field in
deep
and this ball is off the wall
hampson has scored one run game his
story has doubled
well again here come the rockies dodgers
six to five
two out of the ninth dazzle leads from
first jansen delivers
got under it fly ball short left
center field in comes bellinger and he's
got it
and the daunters hang on and win it
6-5 in colorado